I'll sit here do you know my name
though if it is - his real name is
Sebastian you know the cartoonist is
visiting a public school in Bonn I
thought you'd have short black hair
black what gave you that idea
wants to talk to the children about
protecting the environment
he hopes to show them that change begins
at home with simple things like saving
electricity and water and using recycled
paper that's why jeno has created a
climate license
it's a workbook illustrated with comics
in it
polar bear Bo tells Bonnie the lion how
he can save the planet what did you
learn at home Gemma checked whether
electrical devices were switched on when
they weren't needed after completing all
the tasks in her workbook she'll be able
to call herself a climate ambassador
because they work on it at home they ask
themselves how their family could help
the environment it's important that they
get their families on board immediately
you know came up with all the exercises
himself he purposely chose to use a
polar bear because it's a symbol for
climate change that children already
know in the comics bo comes from the
Arctic to Germany he meets Bonnie the
lion who knows nothing about climate
change so he left all the lights on the
TV on even though he wasn't at home
but thanks to the climate license
workbook these children know better Yano
educates some 300 children each year
with his project the 35 year old also
practices what he preaches he gets
around without using a car
jeno likes to listen to music while he
works he earns his living as a freelance
artist and mainly draws for
environmental organizations currently
he's trying to illustrate how the
greenhouse effect functions
very it's very important that the
pictures have a positive effect
the topic is pretty heavy and serious so
you don't need to have gloomy pictures
to tell mr. bilder that so have Jaina
taught himself to draw cartoons it's
been his profession for the last 12
years
one of his employers the Oro Verde
tropical forest foundation is nearby he
often does drawings for them Linda
Ronstadt is an environmentalist as well
her latest project is designed to
explain global warming in a way everyone
can understand the foundation
consciously chooses to use comics and
illustrations in its publications I
think adults also shy away from long
text it's not just children grown-ups
also enjoy simple things and they like
to look at pictures there's a child in
every one of us so when there's a comic
in front of us everyone likes to look at
it
soon Sebastian yeah knows heroes Bonnie
and Beau will be helping children
outside Germany get interested in
preserving the environment he's
currently working on resilient and
Bolivian versions of his climate license
and he's received inquiries from Asia
and Africa as well